ISAAC COHEN: OK, awesome.
So first off, thanks so much to
everybody who's put on tonight.
It's been awesome.
The DJ's killing it.
Like, everybody googled--
these places are amazing.
If you haven't already, I
recommend you go try the bidet,
because those
things are so crazy.
Oh, my god.
Life changer.
Too much, yeah.
OK, so I think Elizabeth
mentioned a few things
at the beginning
about what I do.
I'm Isaac.
I work as an experience
engineer at Leap Motion.
And so what that means
to me is somewhere
between evangelicist and
reckless creator, or something
like that.
Because what I do
is not so much try
to tell people that
our technology is cool,
but just be so in love with it
that I can't help but share it.
I feel really bad
for other people
who are evangelicists and have
to talk about a technology
that they don't
really care about,
because for me
it's actually crazy
how much I love what I do.
I'm trying something a bit
different with this talk,
and actually wrote a speech
instead of just winging it,
so I hope it still sounds OK.
But if it really fails, then
I'll just make something up.
OK.
Oh, the lights.
Perfect.
OK.
So I'm Isaac, and I'm
an experience engineer
at Leap Motion.
I work exploring the newly
discovered relationship
with our hands.
I'm intensely interested in
communing with digital nature.
And the tools that I use
are three.js, Web Audio API,
and most of all, Leap Motion.
Most of what I've
done can be found
at cabbibo.com, where
I've been working
on constructing my own
personal ice kingdom.
Unlike our previous speakers,
I have no idea what I'm doing.
When they started talking
about state machines,
I was totally lost,
and my understanding
of equivalence rigorously
stops at two equal signs.
Don't worry, though.
There's a reason you've been
asked to sit here and listen
to me for the next 30 minutes.
It's because I'm addicted.
To coffee.
I love coffee.
Every day, it's the first
thing that I consume,
and many days it's the last.
I don't consume it because
it's the hardest drug I use.
I don't consume it
because it makes
me feel like a
mental triathlete.
And I don't even
consume it because it
tastes like the delectable
blood of an angel.
No, I love coffee
because I love milk.
I also cannot pronounce my I's,
so it might sound a lot like
"melk."
I love that milk is a different
consistency than coffee.
I love that is differently
colored than coffee.
And I love that when I
delicately combine the two,
it creates the most beautiful
pattern I have ever seen.
It's actually to the
point of obsession.
I never get hot coffee.
It makes the milk
dissipate too quickly,
and isn't as likely to
come in a clear glass.
Regular iced coffee
isn't even enough.
I need cold-brewed,
condensed, New Orleans
ice-styled iced coffee.
Only its viscosity
will satiate me.
At the coffee shop I go to,
they make sure they never
put the milk in
themselves, and always
give me the container
to pour it drop by drop.
People can't tell if
I'm super-conscious
of my milk consumption,
or just straight-up weird.
The latter is obviously
the true statement,
but it's mostly just
because I can't get over
the mystical nature of chaos.
It's kind of funny how this
turbulence brings me peace.
It's such a lonely
joy, after all.
Its haunting dance
into nothingness
is somehow melancholy
in my mind.
I think a bit could be
because, to me, it's
a firm reminder of the
unshakable arrow of time,
or vacuum of space, which
are in many ways terrifying.
But it's just so damn beautiful
that it can do nothing
but calm me.
Maybe it's because I can't
unmix the milk and coffee.
Maybe it's because when
I mix the two today,
they will look
completely different
than they do tomorrow.
That one magical tendril that
I witnessed on the first drop
might be replaced with a
dendrite appearing only moments
before the completion
of the sepia solution.
Maybe it's because any other
individual touching the glass
will create a totally
different pattern.
They will never see the
same turbulence that I do.
Maybe it's because each
and every experience
is only a single moment
and a single branch
of infinite possibilities,
unique and miraculous as it is.
Or maybe it's just the
fact that after it's mixed,
I get to take that
first sweet sip,
and feel the delicious
nectar of caffeine
flowing through my
drug-addled veins.
I hope it's the
turbulence, though.
This would be a much
more interesting talk
if it wasn't predicated on
a deep, physical addiction.
Either way, that moment
when I watch the milk mix,
I find myself in a happy place.
For that moment, rent
is not important.
That giant "Keep Calm
and Carry On" poster
that is now the centerpiece
of our living room
doesn't bother me so much.
And I forget how late I am
to my 9 o'clock stand up.
I find the turbulence
in that cup beautiful,
and that beauty makes me happy.
Not in an urgent way,
in an important way.
I want that peace all the time.
I want to go to my happy
place 10, 11, 12 times a day.
And I've tried doing
that with coffee before.
It was a mistake.
Luckily, as artists--
as I believe
each and every one of us are--
we can create that happy place,
and we can go to it
any time we want.
As magicians, every
time a silly client
tells us to use lime green
to make the text pop more,
we can just load up a web
page, and experience peace.
Experience turbulence.
Here's the thing about
turbulence, though.
To get the detail
you see in coffee,
you need infinite
computing power.
To get each precise flume
and dexterous wrinkle,
you need to get all the
way to the atomic level.
We can get close, but
we can't be exact.
Sure, you have scientists
doing brilliant work
on subjects like
Rayleigh-Benard convection,
but even in their brilliance,
they fall well short
of exact replication.
The butterfly
effect, as we've all
learned from the brilliant
scientist Ashton Kutcher,
is quite a powerful one indeed.
And he just looks so
good in that picture.
Floating point error
is painfully inaccurate
when compared with nature's
uncertainty, Planck's length.
In the end, if I
believe that turbulence
is the most
beautiful art, nature
is the most beautiful artist.
It can not only
create turbulence,
but the snow-dappled mountains,
the powerful rushing rivers,
and every
heart-wrenching sunset.
Nature is awesome.
Nature is so awesome, in
fact, that I've seriously
considered giving up computers
to become a gardener.
They are the
artists, in my mind,
who have chosen
the truest medium.
Anyone who has spent
time in the bonsai garden
over by Lake Merritt
will certainly agree.
The twists are more elegant
than any Bezier curve could
hope to convey, and the sheer
detail of the turtled bark
makes even the most
processor-intensive physics
simulation look like
a crayon drawing.
Any one of us could
spend our entire life
trying to create
that turtled bark
and still fall dramatically
short of our goal.
Hell, all of us in
this room together
could combine our superpowers
and attempt to conjure a tree,
and nature's shaders would
triumph without competition.
If we were physical
artists, on the other hand,
we could use the physical
nature of our work
in order to introduce some
of the beauty of chaos.
Back before I understood
computers gave you superpowers,
I used to just spray
paint on vegetable oil,
splatter it on a canvas,
and call that texture art.
And it was, in many ways,
more than what I create now.
At an even higher
level, I tried to sample
the texture of an elephant's
hide or a toad's skin.
Sampling nature in this time
was many times beautiful.
It felt profound to watch
the flow of the Voronoi
cells of a dragonfly's wing
slowly unfurl into existence
as I painstakingly
etched them into metal.
But even this was a step
away from the original.
Even this was a simulacra.
The further away I got from
milk mixing with coffee,
the more I gave me creative
power, and nature, less.
By doing this, I had to exert
my own will upon the art
that I was treating,
and that meant
that nature was doing less
work, and I was doing more.
Since I'm lazy, and
since we've established
that nature is a much
better artist than I am,
creating in this
way is ridiculous.
I was trying to say the
thing that I could both posit
and execute was better
than a trillion years
of artistic honing,
generations upon generations
of evolutionary pruning, a
masterpiece older than time
itself.
The closest I could get was
mimicry, or possibly borrowing.
I could not understand how
the paint mixed with the oil,
but I could see that when
I haphazardly threw them
on the canvas, it created
something that felt important.
I could not make
the elephant itself,
but I could trace a
picture of its skin,
taking from nature what I
could not create myself.
In this way, to be good
artists, to be good creators,
we do not need to
be good makers.
Rather, we need to
be good thieves.
The Voronoi cells, the
elephant's texture,
and the swirling paint
mixture were, after all,
the creation of nature.
And for me to harness it
in my work and call it
my own was to steal it
from the world itself.
This may seem like
a cardinal crime,
but as we've established,
anything less is preposterous.
What we do is another
step away from nature.
Typically, when
creating a program,
the functions we
create and the tasks we
accomplish have nothing to do
with the logarithmic structure
of fern, or the Fibonacci
arrangement of flower petals.
It's all about
paragraph tags and hrefs
and target equals
underscore blank.
We are the ones that place
these tags on the page.
We are the ones who create
functions and methods, objects
that use objects,
and as we build up
this shoddy tower
of Babel, we tend
to forget how much more complex
the system of an ecosystem is,
and how much less
energy it would
take to destroy our work
than that of nature.
Even when we create
recursive function,
and use math as the
language of nature,
adding one more
layer of complexity
can easily crash our
computer, limiting our detail
to quite childish standards.
Let's not even begin
to talk about the fact
that we are limited to
two-dimensional space,
and that no matter how
many DPI your screen
is, it still crude compared to
even the smallest grain of sand
under the examination
of our retinas.
In this way, our medium is
quite pathetic by any measure
of detail.
Even if we are to sample nature
as a background or a texture,
we are limited by pixels,
memory, and rendering power.
Instead of the rugged
shape of an elephant's ear,
we have to make
spheres and cubes,
and make sure that the
subdivisions are only
of a certain amount,
otherwise our rendering time
will drop beneath the already
pathetic 60 frames a second.
Even AlteredQualia's and
Mr.doob's bump-mapped face is
dramatically less detail
than anybody in the crowd's.
This is not to say it
is any less amazing.
I think all of you can agree
that is actually absurd.
It is just to say that whenever
we do anything in our medium,
we will fall short.
When we try to mimic movement,
when we try to create geometry,
and most of all, when we
try to imitate turbulence.
I hope this is disheartening.
It means that we have
a long way to go.
Our struggle may
not be comfortable,
but if we can somehow emerge
victorious, what a victory
it will be.
Our medium is young.
But if we can help it grow,
and if we can use it to create,
it means that we
have accomplished
something beautiful.
And that accomplishment
should make us happy.
As well, there
are certain things
that are part of our
medium that no other medium
can claim to possess.
There are certain
parts of our medium
that give us a fighting chance.
First off, in our medium,
stealing is in most cases
not destructive.
Because replication
comes for free,
sharing and utilizing
others' code
is widely accepted and expected.
Coding is just socially
acceptable thievery.
This is not to say should go
out willy nilly and jack IP,
just that sharing is caring.
You can see communities
arise from this sharing,
and it makes everyone
involved more mighty.
The best example of this
that I know is three.js.
Because of one man,
Mr.doob's, fervent dedication
to creating a
useful library, many
other of the power players
of the WebGL community
have joined in in making a tool
that lets even someone like me,
who has no idea what they're
doing, create something.
It's more than
just that, though.
Others have let Mr.doob
call their work his own.
In this way, AlteredQualia,
bhouston, zz85, gero3,
WestLangley, and
many, many others
have added to the community
with selfless dedication.
With each additional commit
comes more complexity,
more substance, and
more code to steal.
It may be difficult to
steal directly from nature,
but in this way we can create
complex enough networks
of thievery that
the stealing itself
becomes its own organic being.
For the demo that
I will show you,
I've stolen so much
work from so many people
that there's no
way that I can have
claimed to create it myself.
I've only selected a
mix of others' works,
and put it together in a way
that I've not seen before.
All work we do is not our own.
It is that of our community.
Even in the unlikely chance
that you've built something
using no libraries, the
work that the V8 engine does
in order to compile your
code, and even more,
the work that Intel or NVIDIA
has done in order to render
your program, trumps
any contribution
that you could make
to the overall success
of your application.
Any time you think you have
made something, you are wrong.
You have channelled
organic power
of communities,
corporations, and people
in order to manifest a
creation of humanity.
I can't explain exactly
why, but the miracle
of these different
components coming together
every time I refresh
my browser makes
me think of the mixing of milk
in coffee that I love so much.
Suddenly, my messy room,
the deadlines coming up,
the fact that rent
was due two days ago
doesn't matter so much, and I
start drifting in mental space,
marveling at the smallness
of my own accomplishment
as I consider how
magnificent our species is.
I forget the urgent and
remember the important.
It doesn't just stop at the
channelling of humans, though.
Our medium has something
else that is spectacular.
Variables.
Although I will never be
able to make a face that
is better than the one
that nature can make,
there's something
else magical I can do.
I can change the skin color.
I can even change the
color of the lights that
shine upon the skin.
And I get to do all of this
with a single keystroke.
In this way, I can
create an object
that maybe has less detail, but
has more self freedom than that
which is created by nature.
Although this goes a bit against
letting nature do the work,
there's something
special about variables.
They can be controlled
by another manifestation
of nature-- data.
In my mind, data is
our most fierce weapon
in the creation of
that which is organic.
Because it is so
expansive, it allows
us to pass through one
piece of nature to another.
Although this
manifestation usually tends
to be a one to one
correlation-- say,
placing population
data on a globe--
there's nothing to say
that we can't recklessly
link two uncorrelated
phenomenon.
imagine a faces whose
features are distorted
by the number of endangered
animals per geographic unit.
I'm sorry I didn't
have time to make this,
but I hope that you can concede
it is at least possible.
In this way, we
can begin to create
works which utilize
data to create
an interface between the
natural world and arts.
By figuring out ways
to get real-life data,
we get to make real-life
applications-- real-life art.
There are so many sources
of real-life data.
To me, there's
obviously infinite,
but there are two that are the
most important-- what I hear,
and what I see.
I'm not yet able to rig my eyes
and ears up to a Thunderbolt
cable, but in the
meantime, there
are two ways that I can begin
to access these senses-- the Web
Audio API and Leap Motion.
The Web Audio API is
great, because any time
I want to link audio frequencies
to parts of an application,
all I need to do is create a
stream, create an analyzer,
and call an analyze
function on the update loop.
That's all it takes to get
access to natural data.
The Leap Motion is great
for a similar reason.
All I need to do is create
a controller, connect it,
and now I have access to
something that I can see,
something as fluid and
authentic as the movement
of my own hands.
Because of this
simple access to data,
I get to start doing
strange things with code.
I get to start saying,
OK, make a face,
but also deform it based
on the sound of my voice.
Oh, and also, so that
when I see my hand turn,
make the colors change.
Suddenly, something
that I've stolen
comes to life by funnelling
data from one place to another.
Although I tend to
fetishize the aesthetic,
this fluid data is more
than just a visual nicety.
I've seen interfaces that
feel more playful and organic
than any I'd experienced
pre-Leap Motion and pre-Web
Audio API.
I've seen things created that
were never before possible.
I myself learned to 3D model
and made a mug overnight.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: Lovely.
ISAAC COHEN: Thank you.
Yeah yeah yeah yeah.
It's because all I had to do
was reach my hand in the space
and use the senses
that I love so much.
Because many minds more
brilliant than mine defined
a way to mine the data, I get
to lovingly thieve their work
through robust and simple APIs.
They make the data
easy to thieve,
and as creators, that is the
kindest thing we could ask for.
Additionally, because of
their nuanced connection
with natural data, programming
in with the Web Audio API
and Leap Motion becomes a
pleasure rather than a task.
Although mimicking the
binary click of a mouse
may be less than ideal,
new interfaces that deal
with flow and movement,
and the full spectrum
of human capability
become possible.
Because I can make frequency of
my voice control scroll rate,
or use the position of my hand
to control the camera movement,
I can readily change one
piece of data to another.
And this flow, in my mind,
is miraculous thievery.
It is because in our
medium, there are no units.
Creating a 100
foot sculpture only
means multiplying scale by 100.
Linking gravitational potential
to note frequency only
costs a single line of code.
If I want to change
from XYZ to RGB,
there's absolutely
nothing stopping me.
And that is where
WebGL steps in.
For a meet-up on
WebGL, I think you
might think I would mention
the technology earlier
than two-thirds of the
way into the speech,
but I hope that everything
up to this point
will still apply
to your creation,
even if you never
end up using WebGL.
That being said, you
should use WebGL.
You should use it because
3D is ridiculously awesome.
You should use it because you
can make an entire presentation
in it, and it doesn't
take that long.
But the biggest reason, to
me, that you should use it
is because shaders.
Also, it did take that long.
Now I only learned that shaders
are the truth and the light
about two months ago, so
please take the following
with a grain of salt.
I'm feverishly studying how
they work and what they can do,
but that being said, it's
only been two months.
This should give
you a lot of hope,
though, because if
I can learn anything
about shaders in two months,
it means you can, too.
I'll try to talk
about this a bit.
It's a bit too much
to talk about quickly,
but I'll give you
resources, too.
In the end, WebGL shaders
do two things-- XYZ and RGB.
XYZ is referring to a
vertex shader, which
positions every single vertex
in a geometry, which you can see
here as a cube, and RGB
refers to a fragment shader,
which colors every
pixel in that object.
Together, the two can
deform and color any shape
until it looks nothing
like the original.
We could do a full speech just
about deforming and coloring
a cube in interesting,
ways and I'm
sure that if you
searched on the internet,
you could find
exactly that speech.
But we've got to remember what
we're here for is the coffee.
To get there, we need
to do a few tricks.
Because we can sample
textures into vertex shaders,
we can easily
exchange XYZ with RGB,
basically placing
particles based
on the RGB value of a texture.
Now, I'm going to start
with just a picture, where
we take the RGB
values of the picture
and place them around based
on the value of those three
objects.
So R becomes X, G becomes
Y, and B becomes Z.
Here we can see the pixels
and colors turn to positions,
and see that although
there are these deep reds,
yellows actually have value
that contains R, G, and B.
So it reveals something
fundamental about this picture
that we may have
not known before.
We can take this a step
further and sample a texture
that we've created with
the fragment shader.
In this way, we can color
each texture of a shader,
as we've done randomly in
the middle, giving values
from negative one to
one for R, G, and B,
and then placing each
particle as it corresponds
to its pixel in
three-dimensional space.
Then, by chaining together
vertex and fragment shaders,
we can create one
fragment shader that
talks about position,
and one fragment
shader that talks
about velocity.
Once we link all
this through, we
can do something spectacular-- a
physics simulator done entirely
on the GPU.
What is so special about this
is that all the calculations
happen in parallel.
In this gravity demo,
every single particle
is in an acting
gravitational force
on every single other particle.
We're talking
millions and millions
of calculations every frame.
We're talking, instead
of hundreds of particles,
you have thousands,
even millions.
Now, I should have spent
the entire speech trying
to explain this, but
there are already
a few brilliant examples
that you could look at.
Mr.doob's sporel demo, which
was part of the Google Christmas
experience, is a great
example, and he's
released all of his code.
Zz85's sparks.js is
absolutely sublime.
Zz85 also does a flocking
demo in the three.js examples,
so check that out.
And as well, Soulwire's
straight WebGL GPU particles.
The tasks that they are
doing are all different,
but if you closely
examine them all,
you will learn
dramatically more about GPU
then I can hope to
explain in a short time.
However, with their knowledge
aptly and lovingly stolen,
I can move on to the
Holy Grail, turbulence.
To make my turbulence, I use
something called curl noise.
It is not actually
fluid dynamics,
and I've been told
by few math PhDs
that it's a sin to
even call it mimicry.
It's smoke and mirrors.
But then again,
we are magicians.
Now the most beautiful example
I've ever seen of curl noise
was from the astute
creator Eddie Lee
in his demo Artifacts,
as you can see here.
Eddie Lee's is a
straight-up mastermind,
and if you've ever
played Kyoto or Lotus,
I'm sure that you
will understand why.
He elegantly navigates the
issues I've discussed with
digital creation, both by
creating authentically organic
shaders, or by buying
wholeheartedly into the fact
that his creation
cannot be natural,
and making it playfully simple.
Additionally, he's
awesome because he
let me steal his code.
He showed me how to mimic
my turbulence, my happiness.
I didn't just steal
code from him,
he gave it to me-- free of
charge and out of kindness.
With this code in hand,
I was off to the races.
After hectically slapping
together shader code
into zz85's GPU
particle simulator,
I refreshed my page--
and nothing happened.
I did it again,
and again nothing.
After multiple more
hours of frustration
that can only be
known by someone who's
tripped on a shoelace moments
before finishing a marathon,
I finally asked one of my other
idols, Reza Ali, for help.
Being yet another brilliant
mind and another gracious soul,
Reza sent over his
curl noise, code
which made me realize that
I'd used an equal sign instead
of a plus equal
sign for the most
vital part of the equation.
I told you, I know
nothing about equalities.
But with that bug fixed, I
crossed my fingers, refreshed
my browser, and there it was.
My very first turbulent system.
And by mine, I mean Mr.doob,
AlteredQualia, zz85, Eddie Lee,
Reza Ali, and probably many of
the people sitting in this room
right now.
Sure, it was no milk in coffee.
And I know now that using
more optimized code,
I could get 10 times
more particles.
But it was a start, and
that alone made me happy.
I really think that this
could have been enough for me.
If I committed my changes,
shut down my computer,
and went to sleep, it would have
been more than enough creation
to gratify my gluttonous
desire for the important.
But if I stopped, it would just
be a frail imitation of nature.
It would be dots algorithmically
moving around the screen.
And as happy as I was with
those small white squares,
it is after this point
of initial implementation
that our medium begins to shine.
This piece of code is
in my engine forever.
Now I get to play.
Now I get to create
my happy place.
Now I finally get to explore
in a way that was never
possible in the physical world.
That sunset, though
heart-wrenching,
only happens once a day.
It will never be the beautiful
turquoise and magentas
that I can so lucidly
imagine it to be.
Although I can watch the
glowing ball from far away,
I can never reach
out and touch it.
Yes, we are stuck in simulation.
We are perpetrators
of imitation.
But in that imitation, in that
mimicry, comes a new truth.
It is a hyper-reality we create.
That sun can not
only set in the east,
but it sings to us
if we only will it.
The stars are no longer
a diamond curtain,
but a playground.
We can explore and experience
that which is not possible.
Nature may be a
brilliant artist,
but if we choose to create
with its infinite power,
we have to take on the
shackles of physicality.
Now, with WebGL, with access
directly to the senses,
we can begin to cast
those shackles off.
I'm no longer limited
to my flesh self,
and I can finally come to
you as Cabbibo, the ice
mandala of the northern kingdom,
floating in the darkness.
Nature may want to keep me
here on this earth, harnessed
by my decrepit human form,
but I refuse that requirement.
I will create a
universe where I can
fly through the stars with
the flick of my wrist,
watch eons unfold with each
with each harmonious "ohm."
I will reject common sense to
make the impossible possible.
I will create.
I will leave you now with
one more of our creations.
Please sit with me, and as
you watch its life unfold,
meditate on what is important
to you and what makes you happy.
Think about what you will
do as a miraculous creator,
and how you can harness the
power of the entire human race
to manifest your creation.
As I fly you through our
slowly dissipating universe,
remember that although we will
always be painfully limited
as humans, we together
have made something
that allows us to
be so much more.
Without further ado, I give
you "We Over" by Holy Other.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
ISAAC COHEN: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
ISAAC COHEN: And
check these out, too.